this is pretty much all the information
we have isn't it so if you haven't I'd
suggest you to construct the question if
you are looking at and also puzzling
over it because constructing the
question is what you is your first step
in working out what are the one of the
important features that I can use you
you know we're required to show that the
red and a blue angles are the same and
so it's only one mark which suggests to
us okay
this should pop out quite easily now the
D your first instinct was to talk about
there being on the same arc no excuse me
the reason why the reason why this is
tricky
oh yeah okay I see yeah I see we should
do I think the reason why this is tricky
is because the way it's been formed at
the moment because the pink thing even
Dave misread angles they named it ECB
don't they yeah okay oh okay so they go
all the way yep sure all right when you
think about say the right angle right
you can think about it being formed in a
lot of different ways so for example C E
C B angle ECB is a bit weird because
it's not even in theory it's not even a
cyclic angle because you can see he is
not on the circumference of a circle
right I'm calling it DC B is just as
unhelpful because DS not even in the
same circle as CNB so that's not very
good so what I would suggest is probably
most useful is actually and I don't know
if this is were to really excite you
don't you know how dangerous it is when
you start edible lies they're just kids
confusing I think it would be helpful to
add a B so I'm just going to UM do like
so okay now because a B is a common
chord right it's a common chord so it's
a common chord excuse me in two circles
that are the same size okay now we know
I'm just going to draw a little side
diagram over here maybe you want to do
the same if we have a chord that's the
same a pair of course it's the same
length so for example let's call this
guy a B
and call this guy C D okay we can infer
that here the angles they for the
circumference in a same segment are
going to be equal so you can see if you
have a look at this angle here let's
call this X so this angle over here is
going to have to be the same as this
angle over here let's call this Y okay
if we really know that a B and C D are
the same because if you picture it
imagine a sliding CD over so I'm going
to take CD remember it's the same way if
there's a B so if I slide it over it
will sit directly on top of a B right if
that's the case then this is a very
familiar situation we're going to have
this remember we slid C and D so it was
up here right so now we've got C Y D and
those are angle setting on the same arc
so we know that that's the same but the
the tricky thing is that you just have
to make sure they're on the same side
because there's two angles that rcent
ended excuse me by these arcs on the
circumference there's this one over here
and that's not equal okay so this is
what we know within a circle that if you
had these equal chords so as you go in
the same direction - like the big side
or the little side you ain't equal
angles there now the thing is with this
circle and this circle
they aren't within the same circle but
their circles of the same size right
so therefore the way that I would wear
this is I would say okay um I could as
it were I could move this circle in the
circle together they would be the same
circle because they're they're congruent
right and they would both have this it
would actually be angle steady on the
same arc a B it's just that they happen
to be separated out if ever there
they're the same size okay so I guess I
would actually say my reasoning would be
since this
could have equal radii their circles I
call it one of the nice things about
circles is that unlike triangles your
honor pure triangles are congruent you
need all this information right but
circle only have a single piece of
information that makes them what they
are so if you have the ring equal radii
then the circles are congruent
therefore they both angles angle a C B
and angle what do we call it a DB DB are
equivalent to because they're both
standing on this arc a B they're just
like angles standing on the same arc
right for a single mark that's all I
would expect I could be a little more I
could make it much longer rigorous proof
but it would certainly be like it'd be
four or five lives and for one mark and
they say what's the actual wording of
the question yeah do you notice they
don't say proof and it's a prove so it's
like look we just want you to get at the
idea that they are the same and we don't
need a whole formal structured thing to
prove that okay so at least now we know
the idea it is about this property okay
so now I can say these angles here they
really are equal okay so now what we're
setting out to prove is that this EB
here is perpendicular is that correct
okay so before I sort of watch any
further into it what do you guys think
what do you see if I want to show that
this is perpendicular to that where do
we want to go what jumps out at you if
anything okay which trying was easy to
hear what are their names
see EBS over here and Edie B's over
there I think it's a great idea if
excuse me if the question is correct
then these two are going to be 90
degrees right now if they're 90 degrees
have a look at these two triangle you
actually know a whole lot about them now
right if they're really 90 they've got
these sides the same they've got a
common side they've got these angles as
well so we've already got like you've
got lots of information this triangle
should be should they be Conqueror what
do you think there should be convert
right because if it's really true then
you've got side angle side side angle
side now I don't know that to be true
yet but if I can prove that they're
congruent then these angles will be
equal their angles on what's it called
their angles on a straight line so that
at 180 degrees so therefore I'm home so
can I prove that these triangles are
congruent do I have enough information
okay now remember we just proved that
these angles or we just got to the fact
that I didn't prove it we got to the
fact that these angles are equal we've
already got this side of this side
that's by definition and then we've got
this side what would you ask me to do
aha very good so there's not just um
there's not just these two triangles
here but there's the big triangle that
they're apart of triangle BCD so we do
need to prove this okay so let's let's
do this right I would actually say in
triangle B C D yep yep
so I always as a general principle I
always try to name the features that I'm
talking about if for example we met
alternate angles on parallel lines I
like to name what the lines are is that
required in most cases it's not for
instance in a question with parallel
lines there's often only two parallel
lines so it's like which are the
parallel lines could I be talking about
however talking about parallel lines say
it's just as often that there isn't a
single pair maybe it's a parallelogram
or a square or a rectangle and you've
got you've got a pair of pairs in the
case of talking about tri was here in
trial subs there are clearly multiple
triangles in this situation and I think
it helps us to refer to which ones which
not just to communicate to the market
but also so we don't get confused so
this is the way I would say it I don't
even need to prove that these things are
associate for all I know they could be
equilateral I mean they're not because
eventually going to prove these of naive
but I don't know that yet so I'm not
even going to talk about the word
isosceles I think there's a nicer easier
way to state this wedding I'd say in
that big triangle I can go straight to
say that BC equals BD and here's my
reason equal sides that's these guys
equal sides are opposite equal angles
this is just exactly what I was talking
about one line previously when I when we
were talking about why these two angles
here are equal right well those are
equal angles and in a triangle if you've
got equal a moves they must they create
equal sides okay
so I've got B C and B D this has this so
now I'm pretty much there to prove that
these are Congre because now I have side
angle side side angle side so I would
say there am triangle and I change keys
right in fact this is why a congruence
proof actually has the names the
triangles in it so that you illustrate
what you're talking about
b c e and triangle BD okay so what i got
we got here i can talk about these two
sides i just referred to and I would say
proven above BC equals BD proof above
for the same reason they leave that we
looked at it in the earlier question
I've got these angles BC E and B D so
whenever you've got two things that are
for the same reason which is proven
above in this case you can just say
similarly you don't have to restate the
property and then lastly I would say C e
equals de because in the question now
just be careful a lot of people here
would say given their take give it
I believe if you have a look at the
question the question doesn't say this
like this actual set of simple it says
that is the midpoint right so what you
would say is this is because is the
midpoint that's the reason people tend
to and I was actually just talking to
some users about this last week Friday I
think people misuse the word given all
the time so for example if you get told
a shape is a square right and then
either in a proof you want to say oh
these two sides are equal that that
wasn't given to you it was given that
they were a square and that you used
your understanding of the geometry
properties to then talk about some
features so don't take given I almost
never say given unless the the actual
whole words are written in the question
so therefore these two triangles we were
looking at convert what was the reason
again what was their arm their
conference proof test that we used side
arrow side it's included
s.a.s now from this point I think you
can kind of leap off I would then say
that angle b ec y equals angle b ad
because corresponding angles in cohorts
are equal and then you go ahead and do
the egg goes up in a straight line and
you're done okay does that make sense